I am a shield,
Motoyasu is a spear, I am a sword,
Satsuki is a bow.
Do we need to trust each other's strengthening methods and become stronger? The
three missing heroes are the
waves that occurred after Iwatani-sama was sent to another world.  It
was all well and good up to that point, but of course
you thought it would be better if we didn't make full-scale preparations for combat personnel, which
led to this situation.At
the Colosseum.  I hope we never run into each other.
If possible, I'll give
up at some point and participate in an underground gambling discussion. And then I
'll take good care of you in order to buy back the demi-human from Ruronona village that's being auctioned off. You'll have to spend your whole life earning
money for this medicine.  Are you ready to continue? I'll make
money not just for Patra, but for three or four people. Do
n't take the next direct hit. You'll die. Let's
go.
[Applause]